Steve thank you so much for coming out
to London welcome to winners on a
Wednesday every single week we have
success students
you can't qualify as a success tune why
don't you give us a little bit of
background your strategies being beat
are are buying refurbishing refinancing
am I correct yeah you make it about
three four thousand pounds profit every
single month just packed in your
full-time job so give us the background
story how did it all happen what made
you get into property in the first place
okay so the first job my my boss I was
like a white waiter and a restaurant my
boss was an old-school landlord so I've
kind of fell into like very badly doing
property like just kind of winging it
the first few years yeah so I built a
little mini portfolio over like over 14
years and along side of that I was
always working as a restaurant manager
and I bought my own pub had that for a
few years and then I sort of turned to
be no market trader when out selling
clothes all over the country and you
know kind of them that's that got me so
far
yeah and then obviously a few things
starting to change then we decided you
know arrived but like a we've gotta stop
taking this property came a bit more
seriously now and think about a future
and that's how we've ended up here yeah
so I mean there's so many people that
like accidental landlords or they have
it as a bit of a hobby and I always say
if you treat it like a hobby you're
gonna get hobby like results so what was
what was the defining moment when you're
like right we've got we've dabbled a
little bit but now we're gonna go you
said you had your daughter yeah like was
there a moment or was it just a lots of
little discussions that kind of well my
wife Tommy she was pregnant and I was
working away
I actually working in Bob linens and I
was there with my mate and I was kind of
like what I'm going to do when my
daughter yeah my daughter arrives I
can't be away every other weekend likes
or working around the clock and going
home exhausted is not good to no one and
so I saw at this point had no training I
have my own kind of made up formula
figuring out what was a good deal I
think there was only training out there
so when I bought one more place and
that's come good night they all they all
come good overtime but the deed the
deals have done since have been like
different league yeah but what it was is
I'm known as a dad and thinking you know
I don't want to work from home anymore I
want to want to be a family man and yeah
I'm still gonna work obviously but I
don't wanna I don't want to be one dad
come home Monday to Thursday yeah so you
went from a amateur property
professional where you were a landlord
and you did have promises to like a
professional Tony Danza deals how much
will you make in before you got trained
in your properties were you making a lot
of money a little bit of money I was
doing all right but I had never analyzed
it this way she's always brought up from
the opinion get house rent out pay the
mortgage off it's a savings account but
that's really bad don't do it and then I
start to realize the more you look at
every expert out there they're saying
well that's not bad
you can have this his wages and reinvest
it and grow it and grow it and grow it
yeah so I started to look at that and I
suppose I was make him out to buy now
it's up to 2,300 but that's 14 years of
growth and yes it wouldn't have been
that from day one if that make sense yes
yeah yeah so now we would have been
about 2200 core 2,000 pounds say give or
take a bit yeah yeah and now you're on
how much gonna be just short well the
deals have already done we're gonna be
just short for ya then with the bolt ons
we've got to them we're building an
extension we can be well past fall if
that's great so you've basically doubled
your what you did in 14 years you've
doubled in just literally how many about
six months or something yeah six months
I suppose with time they actually extra
flat bill it will be maybe a year but I
then obviously we've got any other deals
on the in the part as well so knows
where I'll be that's great you know what
it's really good because a lot of people
that comment winners Wednesday they come
on they've got no mone they've got no
property experience and then they get
some rent to rent deals and then I make
2,000 pound a month whereas it's really
refreshing having someone who's been in
the game probably longer than I have I
mean I you know I've been shamefully
I've been in the game like 11 12 years
so you know you've been in the industry
a long time but then having someone
that's you know already in property and
then get actually I want to really scale
there someone to do it properly at one
of the formulas I think is really
refreshing so start at the crash course
yeah we always say all starts at the
crash course what happened what was your
experience of those two days well our to
be honest with you I had actually like
decided to give property mr. an arrest
prior to that item you know I've been
working so hard and I thought made
myself bad over doing it and I said you
know what you know I could I tried
everything and I got I said you know I'm
not dealing more property I'm just not
doing it I'm promised my mom says no
more houses mom and she's like girl
thank God okay yeah and then just by
accident I came across the the YouTube
channel and I came
the winners Wednesday's I thought these
guys are amazing these guys are
absolutely amazing like you know I'm
realized but if I had done a bit of
training before but nothing had happened
you know reflection the company it was
me I hadn't done anything and then these
guys got 20 and they're smashed in a
park and it's happened in every week you
know so well on to the crash course and
I just came back just absolutely buzzing
you just think you know I'm really felt
like I've been bought back to life with
it all as obvious he's absolutely great
yeah and when I'm sort of straightaway
the deal I got was off market I just
chased estate agents like you saying
ring up speak to people talk to him and
did that property wasn't for sale and
next thing you know bought it it's great
that's awesome and then he did some
advanced training with us as well
yeah Ewan did the deal farming
extravaganza you know in the process of
joining the Academy yeah so which is
phenomenal talk to me about after the
crash course what what was the first
deal that you did and so I is a property
of me I um for quite a long time it was
- it was - freehold flats next
commercial building middle converted
already yeah and it was brilliant just
it's 20 percent as it is just a
no-brainer but there's a few problems
with it like him the guys have done the
conversion probably weren't builders so
like it auction it went to auction it
was for all I was a bit cheaper I'd look
at that had some solid auction going to
200 spur looking for 210 220 are they
I end up paying 169 for it because I
just kind of went to the agent and I
said him is that property still for sale
you had no even got anymore I've got
okay so when is he been sold like know I
was I did we got the mammals number a
lot yeah would you mind maybe ring him
see if he'd said it just directly and
that just came outta nowhere and after I
sealed that deal weeks later loads more
people are trying to get it but it was
too late and it we've got that Leo so
did you call the landlord direct then I
asked to but they wasn't so keen a no
idea I was gonna say no they obviously
they they've worked hard trying to sell
it they want the Commission they did a
great job and they reached out to him
you live in Canada it's as it turns out
so like he was hard to reach and it was
kind of a bit fed up with the property
and you can see there's a few problems
with it it was kind of thinking I copied
him with this but we've got it all fixed
for a few grand and tenon's us so that's
great I mean a lot of people would say
all the properties off the market is
gone now okay
whereas you said oh it's off the market
has he actually resolved
can I speak so like pushed I think
that's a great lesson in how you need to
be a property investor you need to
someone that rather than just stopping
at a I don't know actually continues to
portion or something that we do
practically yeah the training what talk
to me the figures in so you bought it
for one two six nine order for 169 yeah
him so it was already occupied by two
lots of tenants they were both saying we
leaving he's a few problems so I just
don't worry we'll sort it I said
obviously now we take a few months to
own it so it's no problem
they both paying six hundred quid a
month each yeah say like it's making is
about 900 girlies but it's a massive
site so now we've just going for you
planning to put a big extra unit on the
back and I've got lots of builder
friends so see quite looking good an
architect friend as well so we're just
basically ovary planning and we'll be
putting at least one more of the same on
the back incredible yeah so once you've
done that then so you buy it for 169 you
renting out for 1200 pounds a month once
you've built how much would it cost to
build the I'm around because I've got
friends and it's local I can for forty
forty thousand yeah and so that means
170 so all in you've talking about
210,000 including the the new bit so
what do you think the own value will be
on that well everywhere I look the flats
or I've already I can't see how I'm not
heavily underpaid already yeah whoever I
look I think wealth influx like 120 110
because a three-hole flats they're not
on their big the great big like
apartment flats yeah so I think he's got
to be he's gonna be knocking for through
minimum 3l another day are the plan to
refinance yeah I've gotta wait for that
one I can't do it straight away it's
kind of the condition of being a
multi-block of but that falls back in
line with the building time yes so like
the end of the two years I could prove I
probably could pull nearly if not all of
my money out of it yeah I know people
just don't realize that you can do this
kind of thing nicer people think you
know save a pretty positive buy a little
house save a pretty positive buy us
that's gonna take you a lot unless
you're on a ridiculously good salary or
football or something skits think about
a long time to become financially free
doing that and that's what most
landlords do I took me 14 years of
overtime to get four properties that's
what I did and now just it's a fun these
flaps are just refinance the one I
bought six seven years ago yeah so like
it's but what you were doing at that
slow way it's did a lot better than what
most people do which is nothing yeah you
know I mean the fact that you were
working hard working overtime saving
buying houses that's the slow way takes
14 years to maybe
2,000 or so thousand pounds a month
which is good that's okay but then what
what do you do different now what's the
fundamental difference between you as a
property investor in 2020 now you've
done the training now you've you've had
a new lease of life compared to you say
a couple years ago I think you look at
it from a different perspective like you
don't look at it like I was a problem of
the house you're like what's a problem I
solve it let's mitigate tenants happy to
keep properties in good condition it's
nothing's a problem you know that's the
first thing second thing is I think how
fast you stuck a deal right now it's
almost like code you just go oh yeah 20%
you think you can do it sometimes about
calculate so if it's round figures so
you straight away when you see a deal
you can know what the rent is and you
know what condition it's in yeah I think
it helps know a little bit about how to
keep the condition of a property good
yeah rough cost in so I think getting a
buzz off of doing it and being ambitious
not being scared to borrow things
massive yeah I was talking about yes so
powerful I mean you've basically just
summed up like I love what we're doing
the crash course which is value a house
pay the rent work out the return on
investment that's the first thing but
it's amazing how many people I've been
in property for decades and they don't
know actually how to do that they talk
about yields or talk about things to do
with feelings and it's actually nothing
to do with what's relevant about being a
professional property investor in my
opinion yeah yeah work work out good
some investment also debt leveraging
money talk to me about that so I've
always you know not wrongly other
meaning of the opinion of the investors
that are now and his you know family
they're like you know he get house paid
off and then you secure investment
you're okay I'm like yeah but if you do
it here somehow you can have two or
three with that money they're like yeah
but what if the interest rate goes up a
lot before you start it's okay what you
mean stacked it I've got what interest
rates after hit 15% for me to be in
serious trouble yeah I mean then the
rents are gonna go up and then you can
always sell one house got to keep them
forever you know you think you should
but you know what and there's no right
or wrong sometimes you know everyone's
wired differently but my opinion is if
you want to be rich if you want to
become a multi-millionaire through
property you just cannot do that without
leveraging when I being smart stacking
the deal correctly and I love what you
said about it's gonna have to go up 15%
or more and it's possible I mean come on
it has been in the you go back before
I was born but it has happened but the
likelihood of that is so slim and even
if that did happen if you've stacked it
right you'd probably be a break-even and
then you can just sell like it's very
unlikely and worst worst worst worst
worst case I mean what if that happened
we'd all be screwed I said that I said
to my wife I said well if we lose the
portfolio the hole couldn't even lose
the house
yeah I say so I feel sorry for everyone
and which is myself yeah I'm happy with
that very small risk and whether you'd
pour your hundred thousand pound into
four or five properties they're supposed
to buying it in one if you put all your
money in one house that's more risky
because then if that house drops you're
screwed you put all of your hard-earned
money in one house as if you leave
you're a jet spread it out you're gonna
get more cash flow more expected capital
depreciation you're the safer position
so I actually know is it better at
becoming rich an arguably but I actually
think it's safer yeah I totally agree
yeah so what sir talked about with you
the deal so that was that one what I am
saying the other day we've done is a BRR
and this one's one where it's we can't
pull all of our money out we can pull
out but we double what the refurb costs
okay but we're not even bite up for own
money so the money's being lent to us so
we're gonna have a probably plus eight
grand in the bank yeah for having a
house that cash flows about 600 a month
that's so cool yeah where did you get
the money from from relative there's my
relative like you know really see if you
ask me about property skeptically and
then I just thought you know what I'll
do I'll just be honest I say well do you
what I get is equivalent to 20% in the
bank I said that's what I said a 0.05
limit to the 20 grand I get but limited
returns on 20% of the right deals and I
don't want to buy anything but I can you
know how do we get involved in this and
that that's been dead simple that's been
really easy so we're doing the reef
doing the reef up we've got tenants way
to old tenants come and rule me up said
Steve you know we wanted to live we'll
take it me know yeah so there's no
actually no lull in waiting for anything
it's all just gonna fire through and I
love about BRR as well as you know if
it's tip-top when you finished when you
do it from scratch
yes sometimes I'll call that board is a
bit old one day that might go well you
know the wirings tip-top the decals
great you've done it all yourself and
you ripped it back to brick so you know
you've got good so true and just for
anyone that doesn't know what you mean
by BRR so you can buy a house and just
dump it deposit in
ready now that's basic bikes are there
what you're talking about what you do
which is great is when you put money in
and then you force the value up and you
do that by refurbishing the property and
often it might be a case of either
presume the properties that you be
buying they might not even be
mortgageable because there's not a good
kitchen bathroom quite possibly I think
this one was just about sure that I
rejoice did you know I needed it was a
shame really the guy has been widowed
and he hasn't looked after the house
hasn't been able to so it's just like
years and years maybe it was it was
probably good Nick 30 years ago and now
it's at a point where but obviously I'll
get what you're saying it's um it's
perfect if there's not mortgage on it
cos yeah then you have a really good
deal
yeah force the value up and then you get
a new mortgage and you refinance pulling
out as much as possible
if you pull all your money out then yeah
laughs in a typically your pool maybe
eighty percent maybe ninety percent of
your money now meaning you're leaving
very little money of your own
into the property so that's cool but the
fact that you borrowed money from family
again it's just so different way of
thinking isn't it because yeah
it's just a different it's like a new
set of rules I think it helps when
you've got one example to show me what
he done I think I have obviously
sometimes uh you know I've got bless him
over the years my dad he would be help
me of anything you know how we when I
bought a problem that wasn't a good idea
you know he was happy to help
we're like when you say oh you know I'm
getting 20% you know this has gone up 50
grand yeah it's kind of obvious guy
maybe you do know what you doing and it
hasn't got to be that big even it was
just a rent to rent you saying I'll make
your name in Japan a month or 500 Panama
this property I think it helps on
getting outside finance if you've gotta
submit to show them I think so I also
think it helps with your confidence
because if you're bit unsure about the
deal I think you will get this much
whereas if you say I've done it I've
been trained a bit I'm experienced
here's the actual evidence of one that
I'm already doing suddenly and that's
why I always say your first deal and
when we met you'd already done deals but
your first deal is always the hardest
because that's when you've got no
experience you've got no confidence
you're but no sir but once you've got
the first good deal then you can then
for instance borrow money you can you
can you can really start scaling so what
are the plans then for the next few
months
okay well I'm excited now I'm really
excited I'm actually the most person
I've been about the work long as I can
remember
yeah because you know pressures not on
in
you know my end of the deals are covered
now you know from from the passive rent
and congratulations because you just
quit the job yeah yeah tell me just tell
me about that quickly cuz that's
exciting
yeah when I was on the road and
obviously selling on the road selling
not a market trader but I'd go to venues
like ledger companies and sell like
clearance where but it's grueling graft
you know it's absolutely grueling Cyril
a great deal probably like anyway it
varies with that game yes one one year
you know I suppose now which is 20k okay
cool there's 20k but it was quite casual
how we did it yeah and it was for me I
only got into that by mistake but now
you're making more in property than you
own your job yeah like considerably yeah
which is just awesome
but for that I had I had 20 30 K wrapped
up in stock and I was like were doing
yeah I'm actually doing it's a lot
harder to shift 30 grams with the
t-shirts how do you feel now after
quitting your job
I just just chilled like oh I love it I
love working I love what I do yeah like
some days if you maybe just maybe you
little girl what's go the part you can
have the odd day off yeah you know or
like just the pressures not on you know
you can you can maybe treat someone to
something little things like that and
we're generous at Christmas you know or
like just I just feel like I can pick
what I do would be better hopefully like
them I want to be better I want to you
know how old is your daughter she's
nearly 200 so cause my daughter's 2 as
well yeah definitely relate to want it
to be at home a little bit more I think
that's the thing I mean I teach property
but really the thing that I aspire to
help people we were just having a bit
more freedom in their life and you know
being able to spend a bit more time at
home to be able to spend a little bit
more Christmas just enjoy yourself he's
gray so go back to my last question then
talk to me about your plan what's the
strategy throughout this year well the
plan is here is obviously we'd get this
build done on the back flap you know cuz
obviously that's that's that all capped
off it's solid and got his lease option
to address it's not me who's and got
contact with the seller
its the Easter build-a-guy so I'm
obviously is his connection so
eventually I think maybe I may have to
like say can i maybe have a word but I
think he's got it under wraps but if
that goes off well because he's saying
list I don't know anything about
property or license in it makes my head
spin but I'll fix everything there just
ring me I'll go around I mean it's a HMO
landlord that's a godsend isn't it yeah
a partner who can fix everything for
nothing
absolutely
I think you know when you become
knowledgeable in proper today suddenly
there might be people I haven't got I've
got money but they've not got knowledge
yeah they've got different but when
you've got knowledge is just searcher
and now you're experienced you've got
knowledge you've got all the inside
tricks and tips so that's very possible
lease option to me what is the lease
option for anyone yeah it's where you go
you intend to buy the property you've
got the you've got the option to buy at
the end of it sure at least so you might
say to a landlord and I'll give you a
fixed rent for a period it's off your
hands you know you have tired landlord
or you you know maybe some reason you
don't want to be a landlord at the
moment will pay you a rent will take
control of the property and look after
it for you yeah and the end of that will
with what an agreed price we're you know
we've got the option we'd fully intend
to buy it and for the landlord it means
I can't achieve more money ultimately
currently yeah and from your point of
view it means you're not having to put
money down upfront effectively it could
be a no very little money down project
yeah so talk to me about if you were
like advising yourself from say a year
ago
what would you because that was when
when did we would it be first me or when
it stood first up comes to crash crash
course in September oh so no even that
long ago just sliced off maybe six
months or that's six months yeah yeah
what would you advise yourself if you're
advising your like one year younger self
in property what are the best things
that you've learned okay and first thing
I'll say just remember to enjoy it
you're choosing to do it so enjoy it
yeah and go easy on yourself I obviously
set big goals and work hard but don't
don't don't or destroy yourself if they
don't happen overnight
yeah because some people they can just
happen this room doesn't it that like
bang massive deals it's flowing not for
me it took a bit longer but now it's
rolling it's great yeah so I think you
go easy on yourself and you know but
keep in mind what you know what the goal
is and lastly he don't do anything else
have some training if this was around
and I started by now
I'm sorry I wasn't doing what can I say
but yeah no I think talk to me about to
the training because you've been on that
you've been on the crash course you've
also been on some of the advanced
training why did you choose to do that
cuz you know it cost us time it costs
money why did you choose to do that and
was it
you can never know too much Kenya even
if you've been to training or you know
for your paper for and you might have
heard it before when you hear the same
information off really knowledgeable
great people who are doing it now you're
like oh that definitely works
you know he's scared to do that you know
these guys are doing amazingly well and
I think you need the and it can be quite
an isolated place to be doing property
on your own right you talk to someone
and they just look through you like mmm
that when you get around two or three
hundred young hungry people bounce in to
the guy who what more DNA than that and
knowledge of people who have not doing
all the strategies they're doing them
now yeah that's I think that's massive
it's not like I did this ten years ago
coffee me it's like we're all doing all
this now yes and that's kind of for me
that's that's great adrenaline to be
following and in the hunger so uh yeah
that means a lot you know the mood I
think it's also I mean the knowledge is
one thing which is really important we
talked about but I always say
environment is stronger than well power
and being in that kind of environment
you're absolutely right and that's one
of the reasons why I actually like to
Train and I get to training courses
myself I flow over the world because
when you're in an environment of people
that support you that want you to do
well again it it can be lonely being an
entrepreneur people don't get it how's
your with your wife with the crash
course she's now I'm dead what's going
on talk to me about you boy how does she
feel about all this craziness she's a
nurse and she she's she trusts me
hundred-percent and she's on my
sometimes if I've got some crazy ideas I
say can you just write all this down
listen to me and tell me what you think
so I'll walk around in circles get are
over verb she knows Ryo she could suck a
deal yeah desperate to drag her to a
crash course but for her she's like look
I've got a job I'm a nurse I've got the
baby I trust you I'm help you when you
need me she chewed her off ago and she
drove over stripped of all paper but
that suits me because she a hundred
percent supports me yeah it's my
business partners next and bringin him
to you crash course this year right
bringing him you know we had the pub
together up said look mate like when a
year you know when you change the job
let's get something started going to
work with me you know so you'll see him
you'll see him this year that's great
and I think it's important of people
around you as well that make sure that
you're not going completely insane
because you can you can get so carried
away I would you have people around you
that
grounded and I'm not talking about being
negative here no one wants negative
people but doesn't support you but at
the same time you can you can tell them
your ideas and make sure that you're not
going completely insane I know sometimes
I feel like I'm going insane I'm buying
the castle I remember just thinking am i
completely insane you know having people
around me say no you're not you know
you're gonna make money on it as well as
love doing it you're gonna learn a lot
you know I think that's really important
so what some big biggest sort of take
away then from from not just not the
training now but from actually doing
there over these last sort of five six
months buying the properties doing the
refurbs well what's been the big
takeaways just do your homework you
think commit yeah you know make sure
you've done your due diligence and you
know however you want to do it you know
make sure you do check the formulas all
right make sure you check the bill
follow everything you've been taught and
then just commit to it don't get cold
feet you've done the checks you know ask
somebody else who's a trained in keeping
contact your network as someone else to
look at you're not sure and it's not
that big a deal is it no it's not that
big a deal just just commit and enjoy it
and just get stuck in and be looking on
to the next thing
that's one thing I do now soon as I'm
finishing a projects I'm looking onto
the next one
because he just gets you so excited yeah
I'm so hungry yeah you know you think
don't want this to end it's great yeah I
think I'll tell you what I think if
you're gonna work hard anyway you might
as well get rich I mean the average
salary is what two three grand a month
best like so in property you makes so
much more than that why not just see the
fact you've gone full time in property
it's a it's a very very exciting yeah
it's a very very exciting future what
does your day to day look like my day
today now well how long have you mean
full-time property no just well I I
decided after the crash course gone as
the DfE I know what could do it because
I just thought their business I just
stick in the business for a few months
to pull more money out yes cuz obviously
that's another part of deposit I've got
a sock in the van so you know nowadays
I'm just em I'm working hard on the BRR
like I'm I know
generally going forward I wouldn't
always be there but because my refurb
teams in my town and then my guys and I
just for me given a few hours I really
do get it done the right money yeah so
I'm involved in that constantly always
looking at deals every day every day
I'll check anything new one you know
what's going on and where do you look
like a right move
all of them go on gumtree or Facebook
anywhere Facebook you get from all done
in 20 minutes can't yeah it's amazing
though how much you can't like for me
Illini on the time like I'm in a [ __ ]
of all property check now instead of
first thing I'll do in the morning
instead of going on Instagram or
whatever I'm just looking for this to
see what new deals have come up and I
think it's it's almost like even if
you're full-time the nooks and crannies
of life we have so much it's time like
five minutes here half an hour here and
evening a Saturday and instead of on a
Saturday choosing to lounge around or go
shopping wanna go look at houses and
then in the nooks and crannies of life
is the scrolling through Facebook how
about scroll through right move yeah you
know instead of phoning your mates and
just say hey what you up to have a phone
a stage in a book of viewing it's just
these small changes that can ultimately
lead to big changes in lifestyle doesn't
it so like just by me saying so a
builder hi I've got this great this
great project do you want to come do the
work he's not what I've got a project -
you want to come and get involved in
like an HMO potential lease option yeah
and not just just talk and be out be out
there just be honest didn't be frank
about you do it and you know you don't
kind of abs on doesn't it
yeah you've spoken a lot about team and
network what tips would you give around
building your power tip I don't know it
might be something that you've done over
the years but like if you wanted to get
a management company builders how do you
find those people I think do I could do
it I can't find what I found again now
in six months
yeah but it took me ten years but I just
learned the hard way really yeah 14
years but I'd say you know tell
everybody what you do not in a in a way
like yes it hasn't got to be loud it
can't be what you do or invest in
property or not makes it build up
oh you know okay John it'd give us a
quote or maybe give him a little job
first to see how they get on and find
out what they might charge and be
friendly with people as well you know
just be a man when you put it out there
I remember I plot on facebook I'm
setting off I'm setting off the last bit
of stock here cuz I'm focus on the
property business one guy calls me I
used to wait on his table 15 years ago
he's like yeah we're getting rid of to
eight your mouse next couple years he
said and and there's a few more bits in
the portfolio just to ring you I'm
sending them yes please I said it just
said what I'm doing just pointing out
this but it politely and gently and just
follow through on what you do and people
know you're a good guy you're not gonna
down and you know the people will come
to you as well what may yahwah's got to
go to them it's great coming from you
because I mean rule number one for me
rule number one of being a property
investor is to tell the world your
property investor and so many people I
see even at the crash course they their
secret entrepreneurs you know they come
in secret they tell you money they may
book the day off and everyone thinks
they're inspired a but actually they're
learning about prophecy and their plan
is to very quietly become successful in
secret because they don't want to look
stupid because if they say they were
property investors and people say how
many properties do it how many they
don't want to look silly and their plan
is to just ultimately quietly become
financially free come on when it's
Wednesday and Tara tell the world yeah
and I always say it's not like that you
need to tell the world first and then
you speak it out and you speak it into
existence and you don't need to be only
great things you said is you don't need
to do it in a loudmouth way so when I
tell people you're going to tell the
world they'll probably because I'm quite
an extrovert I speak on stage I have a
youtube show and a podcast I think wow I
couldn't do that but it doesn't have to
be like that you can tell people quietly
you can just do it in a very you like
why yes what do you think about that
that's exactly right I mean I was always
scared to say anything because I've been
an X problem not as a young one yeah
obviously you must know about this too
soon as you when you're young and get
ISM a big you get a lot of questions
[ __ ] Oh God
you know not always negative but you
feel a little bit like I used to feel
like I couldn't say what my success was
yeah I felt like it I feel like people
think I don't deserve it
but now I'm just saying well no I'm
saying successful I'm just saying I do
property yeah and this is one we've done
and is anybody maybe one over now and
again I mean I might even just saves
anybody want to to rent this house and
then I didn't need it property how do
you do it need some of it oh okay
therefore you know it like you son of a
connection and they're everywhere aren't
they yeah they're absolutely everywhere
in your family that your friends you
know the friends or friends who don't
know what to do of a house it's just
everyone live somewhere every was got a
house they might want some help with
yeah this is really quite clever clever
strategies to just sort of every time
you rent a house it's outside because
you're also telling people you're
property investor in a non because
English people don't like bragging and
I like it a lot higher you know I get
beautiful life you know like whoa but
but but I'm probably more out there than
then you have to be it but that's just
on being true to myself that's my
personality but you can do it in a
little bit more of a subtle way it's
gonna help with finding deals finding
power team the amount of kids I probably
about 20 people and day send me property
deals yeah yeah that's a constantly
coming through yeah I've got a property
I've got this piece of land can you have
a look at it I'll send it often to ban
my property director Hale filter it
throw and it's just an property business
he's actually a people business you know
and you'll probably know that more than
anybody it's the money comes from people
it comes from the tenants it comes from
the sellers it comes from the investors
it doesn't actually come from the
property itself even though the property
will outlive the people absolutely yeah
they've all of us really probably yeah
hopefully why did you use property over
every other possible like stocks and
shares and did why did you choose
property okay well but you say it's
people business so I was like restaurant
manager public market trader I like
dealing with people I don't want it I
don't really want to just be clicking a
mouse all day looking the price of
something that wasn't really for me and
I kind of fell into it a young age we've
like I am my mentors if you will all and
officially all new property like nothing
like this for the marble court two or
three by select and that was there bolt
onto the side of their business so I've
always kind of been involved in it then
I just realize one day like so much more
to this than just like two or three
bites elects where you ever you want
people at the money back in to pay them
down just it's actually the only thing I
found what you can do with a bit of
training that's actually limitless mmm
actually is limitless isn't it you can
do go as far as you want to go of it
yeah if you've got the right knowledge
in right here how far do you bunk test
you plan on being like a million I don't
ever think about the money but obviously
like I said when I got to my portfolio I
got to a million I'd feel like about to
a milestone yeah soon as you got they
like I really I'm grateful you there now
yeah yeah portfolio is just over that
now your own testicle insulation Thank
You negative property millionaire yeah I
know for you it might be almost
embarrassing yeah yeah you're right
you're right that's what that's what I'm
gonna work on I think you know why they
own the title but now it's like well
we've got a million pound portfolio
wouldn't be not to have a million pound
equity in the portfolio yes you know so
we don't put too strict that's just for
a millionaire just a straight mini now
yeah you can only own it because you've
earned it that's right you know
you know you got kids it's massive I
don't care so much about the money I
know you're very much the same art you
don't you know it's not it's for the
reward yes that's about a flat salary
anyway so my properties give me the
salary that's that so for sure it's
about the reward
yeah how about kids what are you
planning on you've got one you've got
one child I've got one little girl now
yeah you wanna you want to see her one
day being a property entrepreneur what I
wanted to see that I think so um I hope
so
but if she doesn't want it she doesn't
got to do it yeah what I think my share
is look so you can do whatever you want
to do no matter how big no small or how
small but like if you put your mind to
it you care about it you love it and you
try hard it is true what they're saying
nearly anything is possible
you know just believe in yourself and
it's a big world ahead do what do what
you another heard I'm so inspired by
people who inspire me like you guys have
my is possible just get stuck in so for
her I can't wait which is honored to
start showing her things I think can be
of used to have not yeah just for the
money helps obviously it's not just the
money there is it it's the it's the
growth yeah for sure
will you send it to a crash course oh
yeah which a six yard
all right kids genuinely and I'm happy
for that if as long as the kids are old
enough to try and listen but it's quite
you know it's quite simple and I think
you know with training I mean as I've
said this to you before state if you
want to do anything if you want to be a
doctor a lawyer a hairdresser an
electrician you need to have training
but people think property just because
you don't need the qualification to do
it professionally you really should you
really fit on it that's what I'm a
trainer yeah what do you think totally
agree yeah like you know I realize now
that if I'd in six to twelve months
training I probably could have covered
the majority of 14 years of costly
mistakes
yeah that's frightening isn't it is well
I'm so glad that you've you've done it
I'm so glad that you succeed and I'm so
glad that you've become a property
millionaire
soon to be equity millionaire which is
incredible so final final piece of
advice then for the listeners you've
been in the game for 14 years yeah
you've done remarkably well you're gonna
be becoming even more successful what
would be the top number one not to put
you on the spot top number one piece of
advice that you give people listen I've
got to do one into two I'd say get
basically trained and be positive yeah
be positive don't look at things as
problems looking problems to be solved
you know whatever it is because you're
not going away by getting angry about
and I think if you can get some help
then it that just safer year I can tell
you now it's a few years you know it
does doesn't it like yeah for sure
so I look at the deals up all now
compared to the deals I bought back
years ago and if I've been buying deals
like this then I probably would already
be where I want to be yeah you know but
after that to wait for ten years of
equity ten years of growth ten years of
rent to feel that benefit but if I knew
how to stack as well and know about the
BRR model I'm gonna be out of my house
as years ago off the back of that bought
four or five more you know it's just you
know you didn't realize how good a
vehicle property is do you until you've
I had to have five six seven years to
look at the equity build-up to realize
oh my god I've made more money out of
this in my job why ever not
why haven't I done more of this yeah the
are powerful crazy so powerful Stu's
been a real pleasure I look forward to
having dinners with you and stuff as
well getting to know you even better and
thanks for coming on the show cheering
you on and respect to quit new job man I
submit yes
[Music]